Here, the only solution is positive 5. Nice work if you got this answer. We'll
start solving this problem like before. We'll change our equation into
exponential form, having the x as our base, 2 as the exponent and set equal to
25. We need to solve for x, so I must take the square root of both sides of the
equation. When we take the square root of both sides, we must include the plus
or minus symbol for the positive and negative root of 25. We know the square
root of 25 equals 5, so x can equal positive 5 or negative 5. But remember for
logarithms, the base of a logarithm must be great than zero. So, we know that
this value x cannot equal negative 5. So the only value that would make this
equation true would be positive 5.